(chop)
(tree creaks)
(tree falls, dispersing ice crystals)
(chops wood, grunts)
(sounds of Damien dragging the wood)
[Celine] Don't slam the door, Damien.
[Damien] (Muttering) Sigh, if I want to slam the damn door I'll slam the door.
[Damien] I saw a flower today. Shouldn't be long now before spring.
[Celine] Or, there's still a few more weeks of winter left and that flower will die, cold and alone.
[Damien] Or...that.
[Damien] Either way, winter can't last forever Celine.
[Damien] With any luck we'll be able to get out of this cabin soon.
[Celine] Luck doesn't keep the fire going.
[Celine] Luck won't change the weather,
[Celine] And luck definitely won't put food on the table.
[Damien] Well, I mean, if you think about it, you probably do need SOME luck in finding something to eat
[Damien] in the middle of winter out in the snow...
[Damien] Ahem, good luck!
[Celine] Whatever. Try not to burn the cabin down while I'm out.
[Damien] Aye Aye, captain.
[Celine] Did you really see a flower?
[Damien] Yes, a little pink one.
[Damien] Silly thing. Probably dead by now.
[Celine] Get some sleep. You look tired.
(slams door shut)
[Damien] You're starting to sound like mom. I'm not that tired.
(yawns)
[Damien] Okay, maybe I am tired.
[Damien] Huh. Well, you don't die easily do you?
[Wilford Warfstache] (off in the distance) Well, why'd the music stop?
[Damien] Hello?
[unknown voice] (echoed) You killed people!
[Damien] what
[unknown voice] So many people!
[Damien] Who's there?
[Damien] Hello?
[Damien] Huh. Alright.
(grunt and a swing)
(snow crunching)
(sound of door opening)
[Celine] Don't slam the door, Damien.
(sound of Damien slamming the door)
[Damien] (rushed) Uh-huh. Yeah, yeah, sure, m-hm
[Damien] I saw a flower today.
[Damien] Shouldn't be long now before...
[Damien] ...spring.
[Celine] Or there's still a few more weeks of winter left
[Celine] And that flower will die cold and al-
(Damien muttering the same thing under his breath)
[Celine] What are you muttering about?
[Damien] I heard... a voice, today .
[Celine] What?
[Damien] I heard a voice.
[Damien] As clear as I'm hearing you.
[Celine] There's no one else in these woods, Damien.
[Damien] But it sounded far away.
[Damien] I should have followed the voice, but it trailed off. And, I had to get back with firewood.
[Damien] But, we have plenty of firewo-
[Celine] Damien, there is no one else in these woods!
[Celine] If there were...(sound of Celine cocking the gun) I'm sure I would've run into them by now.
[Damien] (whispering) I'm sure you would've run into them by now...
[Celine] You're not getting enough sleep, you need to sleep. Are you staying up while I'm out?
[Damien] What, no! I'm fine, I'm not even tired.
[Damien] What about you, are you tired..? You're always awake by the time I get back.
[Celine] I'm not a growing boy like you, little brother.
[Damien] Oh please, you're older by ten minutes.
[Celine] Which is just long enough for me to be in charge so shut up and go to bed.
[Damien] That doesn't make you in charge, how does that make you the boss of me?
[Damien] J-just, just be careful!
[Damien] I don't know. Maybe I'm crazy, but...
[Damien] Whatever I heard out in those woods, it didn't sound too friendly.
[Damien] So just...
[Damien] Just be careful.
[Celine] I can take care of myself.
(sound of her slamming the door shut)
[Damien] Don't slam the door...
[Damien] (Sigh) You always need to be right. Sometimes I'm right...Sometimes I know things.
[Damien] (Muttering) Whatever...
(cracking and creaking)
[Damien] Well, that's weird.
[distorted voice whispering] Damien!
[Damien] What the hell?!
[Damien] That... wasn't there before.
(creaking continues)
[Damien] How did I not notice this?
[Damien] Why can't I see myself?
[Damien] What the hell is that?
[Distorted voice] You aren't quite feeling like yourself, are you?
DAMIEN...
(Damien heavily breathing as the ambiance gets louder)
[Distorted voice] It's time to wake up, Damien.
[Damien] This doesn't make sense...
[Damien] Am I dreaming?
[Celine] Damien.
[Damien] Celine, Is that you?!
[Celine and whispers] Damien!
[Damien] Celine!
[Celine and whispers] (Louder) Damien!
[Damien] Celine, Where are you?!?!
[Damien] (more distant) Where are you?!
[Celine and whispers] Damien, hurry!
[Damien] Can you hear me?
[Damien] Hey!!
(panting)
[Damien] (slight echo) Celine..?
[Damien] (softer) Celine?
[Damien] I've never seen this lake before.
[Damien] I-
(ice creaking)
[Damien] Celine...
[Damien] Celine!
[Damien] Celine! Hold on!
[Damien] I'm almost there.
[Damien] Hold on, just a little bit longer! Just a little bit longer, Celine! Can you hear me?!
[Damien] Celine! Celine?
[Damien] Just hold on. I'm almost there!
[Damien] Hold on! Hold on!
[Distorted voice] It's not fair [Damien] What the hell? [distorted vioce] is it?
(ice cracking and distortion)
(distortions and subtle, inaudible screams)
(inaudible voice)
(Damien screaming, and slowly getting distorted)
(inaudible voices except for) It's been years!
[Celine] Mark's not the only one that can use this place to his benefit.
(inaudible voices)
[Distorted voice] Don't let anyone, ever, leave
(deep reverberations)
[unknown man] (distortion echos) Damien, you are a hard man to find.
[Damien] What? Who are you? Where's Celine?
[unknown man] (chuckles) Now there's a hard woman to avoid.
[Damien] If you did anything to her I'm going-
[unknown man] Easy there, cowboy. I've done nothing to her.
[unknown man] I don't even think I could. That woman would carve my heart out and feed it to me if she even saw me.
[Damien] What...? Then why am I here?! What do you want from me?!
[unknown man] Oh, Damien. Oh my poor, sweet, Damien.
[unknown man] I've come to apologize.
[Damien] Do-...do I know you?
[unknown man] Of course you know me. Dare I say you probably know me as well as you know yourself.
[unknown man] (chuckles) Sorry, bad joke.
Couldn't help myself.
[Damien] I know you.
[unknown man] Oh, come on, Damien. Celine really did a number on you didn't she?
[Damien] Mark..?
[Mark] And circle takes the square!
[Mark] Took you a while friend, but you made it.
[Damien] But this doesn't make any sense. We were just at your party and then we... were...and then you...and then Celi-
[Mark] Whoa there, easy boy!
[Mark] I'm gonna stop you right there because I just don't have time for the whole catching up thing.
[Damien] No, you need to answer me. How did I get here? Where even am I?!
[Mark] Whoa, hold on, okay, alright, I'll just summarize. And it's best summarized by saying that...
[Mark]Mistakes were made! Plans weren't... exactly properly executed.
[Mark] The right people started pointing fingers at the wrong people aaand uh...
(gunshot)
[Mark] A good night with some good friends MAY have taken a wrong turn at some point.
(thunder clap)
[Mark] And okay, I MAY have made a deal to
[Mark] POSSIBLY make sure that a certain lady couldn't go around breaking anyone else's heart, ever again.
[Mark] (heavily distorted) BUT THAT WAS DOING EVERYONE A FAVOR...
[Mark] (distored) But that's all in the past.
[Mark] What matters now is moving forward, and oh how beautiful the future is gonna be with you.
[Damien] You... you murderer...
[Mark] Oh, please, you sound like that idiot detective. Come on, you're better than that.
[Mark] I don't need to hold your hand through all of this.
[Damien] Through all of what? Just leave me alone.
[Damien] You don't realize this place is a dream; a never-ending starring role as the hero.
[Damien] But what is a hero without... a villain?
[Damien] What..?
[Mark] A villain!
Every good story needs a villain!
[Damien] You honestly think that you're the hero in all of this?
[Mark] (small giddy laugh) Well, of course I am! Who else could I possibly be? (small laughter in the background)
[Mark] My humble upbringing, my tragic backstory...
[Mark] There's no other role for me to play.
[Damien] You're out of your mind.
[Mark] Oh, you.
[Mark]  You are going to make the perfect villain in my story.
[Damien] (muttering under his breath) Uh huh, yeah, sure, that makes sense.
[Damien] Well, you can tell your story all you want to the OTHER prisoners.
[Mark] Oh come on, Damien, let it go!
[Mark] Always the righteous crusader! Pure as the driven snow!
[Mark] Acting like you're the only one without blood on your hands!
[Damien] You stole everything from me!
[Mark] (heavy distortions) Well, you wouldn't even HAVE ANYTHING IN THE FIRST PLACE IF IT WASN'T FOR ME!
[Damien] You took our lives! You betrayed me!
[Damien] You betrayed William! You even betrayed Celine!
[Mark] (crumbling sounds) Well, maybe if Celine hadn't run off, then we wouldn't be here right now!
[Damien] You were never good enough for Celine.
[Mark] (multiple voices) I GAVE UP EVERYTHING FOR HER!
[Mark] (distorted) But that's all in...
(normal) the past.
(sigh)
[Mark] And now,
[Mark] I'm here to show you the future.
[Damien] I don't want anything to do with your future.
[Damien] Just go drop dead and let me live my life in peace.
(mark laughing)
[Mark] (deep breath) "Live your life in peace..." oh, my friend.
[Mark]  What has she kept from you?
[Mark] No matter what tricks Celine tries to pull,
[Damien] What's happening?
[Mark] there's no ending for the likes of us.
[Mark] Not anymore.
[Damien] (shivering) What... what have you done?
[Mark] Oh, friend...
[Mark] Like I said, I've done nothing.
(Damien whispers "what did you do" repeatedly)
[Mark] But in this place...
[Mark] I'm gonna make something beautiful.
(Damien stops)
(breaths heavily and inconsistently)
[Damien] I... I can't... (continues to mutter)
[Mark] Damien?
[Damien] I can't...
[Mark] It's time to wake up.
(SLAM)
[Mark] ah...
[Mark] Ah, Celine! So good to see-
(chokes and sputters)
(Mark laughing maniacally as he slowly gets more distorted)
[Damien] I...
[Damien] I have no idea what just happened.
[Celine] Are you alright?
[Damien] No, I'm not alright! I've never been less alright!
[Damien] You need to explain to me what the hell is going on!
[Celine] There's no time to explain!
[Damien] Why does everyone keep telling me that?
[Damien] I spent God knows how long chopping down trees with nothing
[Damien] but time on my side and suddenly now, there's no time!
[Damien] I'm so sick of being a pawn in other people's games.
[Damien] Just give me a straight answer...for once.
[Damien] Celine... am I...? am I dea-
[Celine] No!
(ice cracking)
[Celine] No...
[Damien] Celine...
[Celine] I'm so tired.
[Celine] Everything I've done, I've done to protect you.
[Celine ] But I was too late. Too sloppy. He's undone everything now.
[Celine] But he hasn't won yet.
[Damien] Celine, you can't keep this up.
[Celine] Shut up!
[Celine] You have no idea what I'm capable of.
[Damien] Let me help you!
[Damien] I remember now.
[Damien] I remember what he did.
[Damien] What we did.
[Celine] Damien, you have no idea what's really going on here.
[Damien] You're right.
[Damien]  I... haven't got a clue.
[Damien] But I know that even you can't protect me forever.
(Ice cracks and water rushes)
[Celine] It's... It's not just about protecting you.
[Celine] Everything's different now.
[Celine] The mistakes I've made, the-the people I've used, the things I've had to do to keep you alive!                                                       [splashing]
[Damien] Celine.
[Damien] Some things just can't be fixed.
[Damien] And I'm okay with that.
[Damien] But if you let me help you, then maybe, together, we can start to set things right.
(Celine sighs)
[Damien] You look tired. I think you need to get some sleep.
[Celine] I...can't remember the last time I slept.
[Damien] Don't worry...I'll protect you.
(Ice cracks)
[Celine] You can't come back from this. It'll change you. Forever.
[Damien] Well,
[Damien] he did say he wanted me to be the villain.
[Damien] Maybe he should be more careful with his wishes.
(ice rumbles, water splashes)
[Celine] Just promise me one thing.
Make sure that bastard STAYS DEAD.
(The ice breaks and the house begins to flood)
(sudden loud static)